le couvre-feu tout à l'heure il ya eu
une annonce du premier ministre elle a
pris les bonnes décisions pas la france
on est toujours confronté au même
problème c'est quoi bah c'est savoir moi
on fait des trucs mais pourquoi on les
fait je veux dire on en a mais on va pas
en sortir c'est à dire qu'on fait chier
les français est français on ne sait pas
grave si on les fait chier à condition
qu effectivement ça soit nécessaire pour
la lutte contre l'épidémie et on est
toujours confronté au même problème
c'est que mis à part un ministre qui
s'auto congratule en disant que tous les
scientifiques s'accordent à dire que le
couvre-feu marche alors s'ils marchent
tellement que c'est pour ça qu'on pense
à un confinement
ils marchent tellement que c'est pour ça
qu'ont confirmé c'est pas grave et le
problème c'est qu'à un moment donné
qu'est ce qu'on fait jusqu'où va et
combien de temps je pense qu'il faut
vraiment réalisé qu'un en 2000 en est à
bout vous les français sont à bout ils
n'en peuvent plus et que ça marche pas
abandonner une épidémie il faut accepter
cette part d'imprévu les pays qui ont
confiné compacte ou filet ont les mêmes
courbes dakota du nord dakota du sud
californie floride j'ai les courbes des
deux dakota les coupes sont les mêmes
dray j'arrive de 1000 de miami où tout
est ouvert tout est au vert tranquille
il n'y a pas de rentrer c'est même pire
parce que le gouverneur de floride tout
au départ avait effectivement décrété un
confinement en mars avril
le problème c'est qu'il n'a pas été
respecté du tout parce que la floride
que je connais bien et on peut essayer
la floride ouais je connais floride
effectuant un cabinet aux états unis
donc j'ai des cabinets ça me permet de
parler de choses que je connais bah oui
à vos ceintures et que du coup on
s'aperçoit de coin que la californie qui
est la gauche qui l'a confirmé deux ou
trois fois la clé la misère ils ont
battu ram isr ils ont vécu ils ont les
mêmes courbes dakota du nord a confiné
pas le dakota du sud et on a les mêmes
courbes mais regardez on voit bien que
c'est le premier qui a dit que ce n'est
pas une catastrophe en france que ça va
ça se passait bien que pour l'instant il
n'y a pas de raison de confiner donc en
fait ça mais qu'est ce qu'ils croisent
catastrophe maintenant on a les chiffres
quand même un plat chaud ça veut dire
plateau nomi et on est tous
non mais ce qui est intéressant c'est ça
commence quand la campagne d'andré james
quand tu es sia géraldine non moi je
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec la
positivité non moi je trouve
effectivement on a pris on a fait plein
d'erreurs ça c'est sûr il ya eu plein de
pleins de gags à delà après la situation
est un peu exceptionnel aujourd'hui même
où il est il est dans votre team c'est à
dire qu'il avait lui même prendre le
lead il à venir écouter les sanitaires
on vous a beaucoup écouté globalement
quoi qu'on ait fait massa a jamais
vraiment fait ce que vous aviez jamais
passé vraiment ce que vous avez dit
qu'il se passerait donc maintenant on va
reprendre une vie à peu près normale et
petit à petit on va desserrer l'étau et
de trouver le truc en fait c'est de se
vacciner parce qu'en fait vous avez
raison en allemagne ils ont confiné
strictement tout ils ont tous fermé et
ce en train de repartir
donc en fait y'a pas dragon c'est pas le
coup le couvre-feu dans et le
confinement le week end on n'a pas de
recul sur dunkerque et sur nice dont
finalement bon on va pas le faire donc
en fait on sait pas en fait que le colis
est toujours devant nous et a toujours
deux coups d'avancé sur nous mais vous
savez à est-ce que vous savez comment la
brouille la grille de 1957 la grippe
pandémique 57 qui était donc là la
grippe asiatique
c'est terminé no comment et là on sait
pas